[Music]
alhamdulillah
what lesson can can
we take from that
sh
the fact that these people can say
alhamdulillah is
uh I just want you to think about that
as as you complain about anything
happening in your life know
I yeah alhamdulillah all you can say is
alhamdulillah the fact that they can say
alhamdulillah with all that happening is
um is a great sign of Iman it's a
miracle of faith I just hope that you
know a lot of times we become
disconnected in our um
we become entirely disconnected from
from these people and when you forget
Allah you forget yourself and you forget
other
people
um you know the last conversation that I
had with um a distant cousin of
mine uh before his his I don't know what
happened to his phone I just said you
know just um keep saying immediately
alhamdulillah the fact that these people
still say
alhamdulillah it is it is nothing short
of a miracle and it puts us to shame in
our own lives